ok today we're learning about energy
stores so there's 8 different ways that
energy can be stored and we're going to
learn about each one now energy can be
transferred between the different stores
but today we're just focused on the
stores themselves so the first one we're
going to focus on is the kinetic energy
stores so whenever we think about
kinetic energy the word key word we're
thinking about is movement so if this
person runs faster this person has more
energy in the kinetic energy store the
second type of energy is gravitational
potential energy so any object in a
gravitational field that has the
potential to fall has gravitational
potential energy so if I lift this rock
up further from the Earth's surface it
has more gravitational potential energy
as I lift this pen up closer towards the
camera
I'm giving it more gravitational
potential energy next up its chemical
energy so chemical energy is any type of
energy which sorry anything which can
release energy by a chemical reaction
now there's two main examples that we
need to think about or would need to
know the two examples we need to know is
food and fuel now these are meant to be
little lumps of coal right here so
whenever we have food or fuel that's
type of chemical energy because it's
energy stored within these that's
released when a chemical reaction is
occurring next up is electrostatic
energy now this electrostatic energy is
when we have charges so if we have
opposite charges they're going to
attract if we have two charges with the
same for example both positive they're
going to repel so attract means come
together repel means go apart an example
could be someone who has rubbed their
hair a head against a balloon giving
both the balloon and the hair opposite
charges and then it causes them to
attract like this okay next up is
magnetic
now magnetic energy I guess is kind of
similar in a way
- electrostatic in the way that we have
attraction and repulsion so if I just
quickly draw these poles of the magnets
on here the top one because the poles
are opposite so we have self next to
north and north next to South because
these are opposite these are going to
attract whereas the bottom on here
because they are the same pole next to
each other these are going to repel so
that's what magnetic energy is all about
next up we have elastic potential so I'm
going to draw a little example right
here which is of a slingshot so as I
pull this slingshot back I'm giving this
object more elastic potential energy
more energy in the elastic potential
store so whenever we're dealing with
stretching of a material we're putting
more energy within the elastic potential
store okay next up is nuclear energy
now nuclear energy is energy which is
stored within the nucleus or in the
nucleus of an atom so just as a little
recap here's my nucleus remember
electrons go around the outside so it's
energy which is stored within the
nucleus which could be released when we
have nuclear reactions for example in a
nuclear power station number eight and
the final one is thermal energy so
thermal energy I'm just going to do a
little diagram here to show a
thermometer so Fermin energy is
basically when we're thinking about Heat
so so when an object is hotter it has
more energy in the thermal store so
those are the eight different types of
energy but there's just a little way
that I've come up with to help everyone
remember them which is kg cement so
imagine a kilogram of cement so
this stands for each of the different
energy stores so we have kinetic
gravitational potential energy chemical
electrostatic magnetic
elastic potential nuclear and thermal so
we just need to remember this kilogram
of cement kg cements and those are your
eight different energy stores thank you